على سطح مبنى صناعي
في هونغ كونغ ، يقوم روبوت برسم
روبوت آخر اسمه صوفيا وربما تكون
أشهر أندرويد في العالم اليوم.
مرحبًا بكم في شركة هانسون للروبوتات ، أنا
مندهش كل يوم تقريبًا من الأشياء الجديدة
التي يمكن أن تفعلها الذكاء الاصطناعي والروبوتات
في العالم ، وأعتقد أننا بدأنا للتو في
استكشاف الاحتمالات ،
فلنقم ببعض رياضة تاي تشي ، حسنًا ،
ابدأ بذراعيك  لأسفل
الآن ارفع ذراعيك لأعلى مثل هذه
الاحتمالات ، يقول ديفيد
هانسن ، الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة هانسن للروبوتات ، إن ذلك يشمل الرعاية الصحية
حيث تقول الشركة إنها تخطط
لإنتاج روبوتات شبيهة بالبشر على نطاق واسع بحلول
نهاية العام
، فلنتحدث عن نعمة أخت صوفيا
التي كشفت عنها مؤخرًا
وصفتها بأنها  يا له من مساعد روبوت بشري ،
كيف تعتقد أنها
ستغير عالم نعمة الرعاية الصحية ،
وهي مصممة
للتواصل مع الأشخاص
العاطفيين  باستخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي والروبوتات في
هذا السياق ، يجعل هذه الأنواع من
الشخصيات والوكلاء في
متناول الأشخاص بطريقة تفاعلية ،
ما الذي تفعله يا غريس ، لقد ولدت في عام
2021 وأنا مساعد طبي محترف
متخصص في رعاية كبار السن ،
أريد أن يشعر الجميع بالراحة
مسترخيًا وفي المنزل صُنعت لرعاية
[الموسيقى]
يقول هانسن إن تحقيق ما يسمى
بوهم الحياة في روبوتاته يمكن أن يساعدهم على أن
يصبحوا أكثر فاعلية في تقديم الرعاية
ليس المقصود منهم استبدال الأطباء والممرضات
ولكن لمساعدة الأشخاص الذين
يشعرون بالقلق حيال  روبوت يلعب
دورًا حساسًا وحيويًا مثل
المساعد الطبي ،
كيف تستجيب لأن
التكنولوجيا أصبحت آمنة للغاية ، لذلك لدينا
العديد من طبقات الأمان وخصوصية البيانات ،
فالروبوت هو مجرد وكيل
لخبرة أخصائيي الرعاية الصحية الخاصين بك ،
كما يقول هانسن  أن
الوباء أعاد تنشيط الاهتمام
بالروبوتات لتولي وظائف تعتبر مملة
قذرة وخطيرة في أكتوبر الماضي ،
الاتحاد الدولي للروبوتات
قال إن مبيعات الروبوتات الطبية لديها
القدرة على مضاعفة أكثر من 11
مليار دولار أمريكي بحلول عام
2022. وفي سنغافورة ، فإن احتضان
الأتمتة هذا جاري
على قدم وساق ، حيث تتمتع دولة المدينة الواقعة في جنوب شرق آسيا
بأعلى كثافة روبوتية للفرد
في العالم.
تعتبر سنغافورة مدفوعة بالروبوتات الصناعية فريدة تمامًا
لأننا لا نمتلك أي
موارد طبيعية باستثناء القوى البشرية المناسبة للبشر
، وبسبب ذلك
نحن تكنولوجيا احترافية للغاية ، وبعبارة أخرى ،
تشبه سنغافورة مختبرًا حيًا ،
مستشفى شانغي العام هو أحد هؤلاء
الذين يعيشون  المختبر هنا في بيئة مستشفى تمت
محاكاتها لـ CNN نظرًا
لأن الروبوتات الوبائية تؤدي مهامًا
مثل عمليات تسليم العلاج الطبيعي والتحفيز الاجتماعي ،
توجه سيلينا سيا
برنامج الروبوتات بالمستشفى المعروف باسم
الرسم البياني والذي جلب أسطولًا من أكثر
من 50 روبوتًا إلى أجنحته.
تمثل عقبات كبيرة أمام
إدخال الروبوتات إلى مكان العمل ، فقد
كان اعتماد الروبوتات في الرعاية الصحية
أمرًا لا بأس به  يمثل تحديًا لأنه
ليس حقًا تقنية التوصيل والتشغيل
وهو مكلف
للغاية ولم يثني
المطورين السنغافوريين عن الحلم
باختراعاتهم الخاصة بإنشاء روبوتات يمكنها
تعقيم الأماكن العامة مثل
روبوتات التنظيف الصديقة من
النقطة العمياء التي يمكن أن تزيل
الجهاز الهضمي  الأورام دون الحاجة
إلى شق وإيما
مدلكة روبوتية من أنا أعالجها والتي
تستخدم في الطب الصيني التقليدي
لديفيد هانسن الذي ابتكرت شركته
صوفيا والآن تتمتع الروبوتات جريس
بقوة تحويلية للرعاية الصحية وما
هو أبعد من ذلك فهي فرصة
لنا للتطور
إلى الأمام للتكيف
مع العالم والمواقف المتغيرة
ويمكننا استخدام هذه التقنيات لجعل
حياة الإنسان أفضل وأكثر أمانًا